and so my goal is I want to have videos
uploaded of every single character
clearing classic mode so I got a few
guys unlocked already I've already
cleared it once with Samus but I'll do
it again just for for the stream tonight
Samus is the only one of even attempted
classic mode with so far
who's your main Samus has always been my
main loved Samus but from what I've from
kind of the early indications which it's
still so early there's a lot of things
that can change in terms of the meta and
all I mean because there's so much that
people will discover from now over the
next week over the next month even over
the next year of smash but right now it
seems like that Samus is unfortunately
kind of a lower tier character but I
still love sighs all right let's turn up
since it's the intensity this time
higher the intensity stronger the
enemies and greater the rewards so last
time I started to and it actually
increases as you go along anyway okay so
let's I have no idea how this is gonna
go this is as high as it'll let me start
and then I think by the end of this
it'll actually be all the way up to the
level nines but I've been fighting left
oh gosh
no I always forget there's so much less
loading on smash or on any Nintendo game
really
that cartridge technology what is that
cartridge technology guys okay what is
it even like this doesn't like he's not
even attacking me it is the first one so
he's meant to be easy there we go
alright so it uses a traditional smash
difficulty system of nine being the max
level so you saw how that increased a
little bit I mean see they're like right
now they're not even attempting that oh
there he goes okay
it's also weird and playing classic and
having items on because I get so used to
playing without items my friend and I
when we would play in high school weep
you know first introduction to smash is
for a lot of people it's a party game
right and then the more you play it the
more you start to realize how in depth
it is now kind of annoying and cheap
some of the items are so then you start
playing without items in those more
competitive settings so my friend Neal
and I in high school we would just like
final destination battlefield no items
over and over and over and over it again
we would play and play and play so
whenever I do classic and see an item it
always kind of throws me off
okay horde battle here let's go rob the
Wally look-alike I guess you could say
Wally actually looks looks like Rob
right because Rob was first man
yeah so apparently like the unlocking
characters is tied to how much you like
walked in the game but then there's like
a 10-minute timer on it or something
it's kind of weird
Wally is her Robin Foster yeah I gotta
get that right Wally didn't come first
did you ever have a Rob Chris tallien I
don't think I ever knew anybody who had
a Rob it feels like one of those niche
things
because I don't remember a lot of people
having it but no you didn't have one
yeah I don't know if I've ever seen one
in person but I guess it was a game in
kind of mixed with a toy oh boy
Smash Ball folks he's the last one but
let's try and get this oh come on let's
let's end it in style here and he's just
gonna dodge it of course Oh brilliant
man what an epic epic use of the Smash
Ball I'll go ahead and finish him the
old-fashioned way
trackpad was probably the most obscure
nintendo product was that the super
nintendo one four four Mario Paint that
came with like the little mouse my wife
has them still has the mouse and the
little like mouse pad that it came with
for Super Nintendo version of Mario
Paint dude I'm so ready to unlock ridley
he looks awesome how long have we
Metroid fans wanted Ridley in Smash I
love red lady I just love all things
metroid anyway biblethump
have that too but no the dance pad like
thing for the NES Trek I don't know if
I've seen this one oh he got hit by the
lava oh so did I but I'm good yeah if
you're if you're a halfway-decent smash
player at all you should probably crank
up the difficulty on classic when it
starts or maybe I shouldn't be saying
that yet maybe I should wait till I beat
it here but all right now these guys all
against me or can they yep they cannot
hit each other you see that it looked
like Bowser kind of pushed Mewtwo ahead
man these are all I think Mewtwo's
classified is a heavy character now wow
that's not good I got plenty of gold
we're gonna continue this for sure see I
should I shouldn't started saying oh man
it's it's not bad at all that was the
prescient have died there anyway but
what I was about to say is all these
guys are heavy characters which means
they're gonna be hard to knock off and
they do lots of damage and it's easy for
them to knock you off
there we go there we go
Oh No Mewtwo's got that attack - very oh
man I thought my missile would cancel it
there we go come on get him off get him
off screen no no no there we go yeah see
there you choose a heavy now so it's so
hard to knock him off no there we go
my favorite I think everyone's favorite
smash minigame dude yeah they took out
them they took out the home run thing
home run contest that's so weird that
they took that out that was like you're
right that was the biggest everybody
loved that minigame
I don't know why they took it out cuz I
mean they obviously this the smash to
end all smashes they've included
everything in terms of characters yeah
dude at least I haven't found it yet I'm
pretty sure I read where people were
like begging for it hoping that they're
gonna add it maybe with like the DLC or
something or add it as an add-on later
I can't yeah I was I was stunned how
could you not have the home run contest
I also want to unlock Dark Samus - I
don't think there's any differences in
terms of I can't believe that grab went
through
[Music]
oh gosh I hate when the stages change up
that's the other thing my friends and I
would always turn off turn off the stage
changes items ah there we go
I'll double-check after this for
Stallion but I don't I don't think it's
in here
all right 7.9 we've worked our way up to
the 7.9 difficulty and looks like we got
two more now I think this is to replace
the old break the targets mini-game oh
oh no no I didn't realize the bottom one
would break oh well Master Hand and
crazy hand let's go dude good old Master
Hand and crazy hand it wouldn't be a
Smash Brothers game without him
they kind of changed up how their oh
gosh they changed up where their health
appears in this one
it's at the top now instead of appearing
on the bottom with with yours
like it used to as a character
what it what is the fire did Nana like
goat I don't think I've ever seen that
it's gone now what is this the Thane of
snap I don't remember that
all right master hands getting pretty
low sit you like unique but now iconic
bossfight the master hand there we go
get out of the way get out of the way
get out of the way
[Music]
come on he's almost done there we go all
right master hands done crazy hands
pretty weak no no no come on come on
come on let me dodge let me dodge there
we go
what in the world that's new
[Music]
I might be dead one good thing about
samus's she is heavier nail - she's
harder to knock off no dang it dude I
wanted to beat that one without
continuing they also handle the
continues different now like now it's
it's obviously not gonna be too crazy of
a challenge since it puts me right back
in with him already weak there we go
stealing your work I didn't even see
that that's hilarious
Chris dalian I said almost exactly what
you typed there final round clear all
right let's see if we open up any new
characters
[Applause]
so I guess if you don't dye any you make
it all the way over to the to the far
end I guess you can get all the way up
to nine
yeah this is changed to now
oh my gosh and you hit start it moves so
fast final results quick man oh sweet I
left a lot of spirit spirit items there
we go
it was that looks like dr. Robotnik he's
not in this game oh yeah then the
pokemon in sin Aurora
see I don't after like what there's so
many generations of Pokemon now oh
that's a cool move right there
tink is a Tex hit for pretty hard too
yeah after like gin too I don't know any
Pokemon
in cinah roar he looks cool I'll say
that some of the Pokemon looks so you
know kind of dumb but I think he looks
pretty cool he's a lot smaller than I
thought though I mean he's like the size
of Samus I kind of pictured him as a
Bowser Charizard type character
see you later buddy welcome to the
roster man in center or joins the battle